I'm Russell Kay comedian and podcast
host I'm also a massive John Lennon fan
music that cuts across generations easy
the greatest pop star ever or was he
just a bit of a git
[Music]
[Music]
in an interview in 1980 he admitted that
he was violent and cruel to women he
said I used to be cruel to my woman and
physically any woman I was a hitter I
couldn't express myself and I hid I
fought men and I hit women
a drunken John once attacked Bob Willa
he was the man responsible for
introducing the Beatles to Brian Epstein
their manager Bob had been joking that
John and Brian were in an intimate
relationship and John just lost his
temper started hitting him and he only
stopped because he thought he was going
to kill him Walla was left with several
broken ribs and admitted to hospital
lovey does that sound like a bed
cheering give peace a chance hippy
how can one preach love and practice
hate if you really mean the love you
wouldn't be practicing something so vile
and vicious something else you might not
know about John Lennon he wasn't a great
dad either in fact he was pretty
horrible to his first son Julian Julian
said dad was a hypocrite he could talk
about peace and love to the world but he
could never show it to his wife and son
in fact John Lennon hated his own sons
laugh once he turned to him and screamed
I can't stand away you laugh lovely day
out with Daddy anyone so maybe all this
social campaigning all of this genius
was just a PR campaign to cover over
what a nasty get the man really was I
mean I love Yellow Submarine but not
enough to condone the psychological
scarring of a child so was John Lennon a
musical visionary genius or a violent
misogynistic bully you decide thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon